estamos en el examen número 8 sección
número 5 página
855 y estamos empezando una nueva
sección así que el problema número uno
dice si x entre x menos 2 esto es
exactamente igual a 39 entre 37 a lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale x y bueno
aquí hay dos formas de resolver este
problema la primera sería pasar cruzando
este 37 para acá y este x menos 2 para
acá pero la otra es que tengas un poco
de intuición conserve la calma y te des
cuenta el patrón que cumple justo esta
igualdad fíjate bien dice x entre x
menos 2 es lo mismo que 39 entre 37 si x
vale 39 39 menos 2 es lo mismo que 37 y
se cumpliría esta igualdad por lo tanto
es mucho más rápido darnos cuenta que x
va de 39 y ponerlo justo aquí x vale 39
y tener la respuesta correcta hacer toda
la ecuación de primer grado que
corresponde a esta ecuación que tengo
aquí
bien si tú no lo ves a simple vista lo
podrías multiplicar y decir bueno
nuestro sobrino que 37 x igual a 39 que
multiplica a x2 y de aquí resolver esta
ecuación
37 x es igual a 39 x menos 39 por 2 lo
cual es 18 llevamos una 78 y después
pasar este para que esté para acá y me
va a quedar que 78 es lo mismo que 39 x
menos 37 equis y después decir bueno
esto es lo mismo que 12 x y aquí tengo
78 entonces x debe de valer 78 entre dos
lo cual es 39 y llegamos justo en la
misma respuesta con una ecuación de
primer grado
ahora recuerda que cuanto tengas un
problema de la siat en estas
contratiempo es decir que si no se te
ocurre la respuesta en menos de 10
segundos o tu procedimiento es muy largo
entonces debes de cambiar la forma de
ver el problema en este caso es mucho
más rápido y encuentra la solución muy
fácil si tú te fijas en el patrón entre
estas dos ecuaciones y además más si
estamos en el primer problema
una sección recuerda que los primeros
problemas siempre son más sencillos que
los últimos problemas pero bueno ya está
aquí el problema número uno
pues el problema número dos vamos a
trabajar con el segundo problema y dice
o dicho tengo una tabla esta tabla está
hablando de estudiantes de una clase de
biología avanzada y tengo a aquí a los
hombres hombres ok tengo por acá a las
mujeres a las mujeres o que tengo aquí a
estudiantes de penúltimo grado
penúltimo último por el canal 2 de
último a los de último grado último
último y aquí tengo el total y bueno
también de este lado tengo al total
total así que imagínate que aquí tengo
una tabla y vamos a llenarlo con los
datos tengo acá acá
n m r s t u v w x y z y z ok y qué datos
me dan o más bien que yo preguntan en la
tabla siguiente las letras k n m r s t v
w x z todas estas letras representan el
número de estudiantes de cada categoría
cuál de los siguientes incisos equivale
a z cualquier siguientes incisos
equivale a esta 7 de acá y bueno lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que estas
siete de acá la encontramos a pues
podremos sumar estos dos si sumamos la
cantidad de hombres y mujeres nos daría
el total estudiante estás de acuerdo
el total de hombres y el total de
mujeres me hace tan pero no están mis
respuestas así que podemos pensar en
justo estoy acá la suma de estos dos
también me debe darse tan w x es igual a
z porque los estudiantes del penúltimo
grado más los de último grado que son
todos los que tienen que en esta tabla
me deben dar el total pero tampoco está
en las respuestas y bueno también quiero
que te des cuenta que si nosotros
ponemos todos estos si nosotros nos
tomamos camps más n más ere más ese es
decir la suma de estos cuatro también me
da z porque si somos los hombres de
penúltimo y los hombres de último me da
el total de los hombres las mujeres
depende último de las mujeres del último
me da el total de las mujeres y entonces
la suma de todos estos me debe dar z que
justo es mi respuesta mi respuesta es
que se dan es igual acá más n más r más
s -es el inciso y es el inciso y ya está
la respuesta es la suma de estos así que
vamos a resolver el problema número tres
problema número dos vamos al problema
número 13 y dice y tenemos una figura
más o menos así así que déjame pintarle
una línea por acá tengo otro por acá y
tengo otra por acá algo más o menos así
y qué datos me dan bueno me dicen que
este ángulo este ángulo vale 25 grados
por cierto aquí se llama a aquí se llama
aquí sería ese y me dicen que esté aquí
vale 60 grados ok y este vale x y de
hecho es justo lo que me preguntan
cuánto vale x y quiero que te des cuenta
que esto es el fuego de los ángulos lo
único que hay que hacer es cazar ángulos
y tener mucho cuidado ahora lo primero
lo primero que quiero que saquemos es
este ángulo de aquí este ángulo de aquí
nos va a servir bastante porque está
dentro de este triángulo de hecho este
problema yo creo que es bastante fácil
si has visto varios los vídeos de ls ate
y bueno este ángulo de aquí es
suplementario este por lo tanto 60 más
éste me deben dar 180 grados o dicho
otra manera este ángulo de aquí es 180
menos 60 lo cual son 120 grados 120
grados más 60 me dan 180 que es justo
este ángulo de aquí ahora como obtenemos
este de aquí bueno pues eso lo podemos
obtener muy fácil con una ecuación que
diría x más 25 grados más 120 grados es
decir los ángulos internos de un
triángulo debe de ser igual a 180 grados
a 180 grados del lujo entonces aquí ya
puedo despejar a x x más 145 grados esto
es igual a 180 grados y ahora si restó
145 grados de ambos lados de esta
igualdad nos va a quedar que x es igual
am a 180 menos 145 es 35 35 grados es lo
que vale x de lujo inciso c
borremos la pantalla y vamos ser el
problema número 4 el problema número 4 y
dice el refrigerador de carlos está
descompuesto y costará tres mil pesos
arreglando ok costará arreglarlo
hablarlo costará arreglarlo costará tres
mil pesos ok esto está muy raro
tres mil pesos tres mil ok después dice
por otra parte un nuevo refrigerador
costaría nueve mil pesos ok uno nuevo
nuevo cuesta nueve mil pesos nueve mil
pesos de lujo sí por no usar el
refrigerador se está ahogando 150 pesos
mensuales de luz están en padre carlos
se ahorra hace ahora
a 150 pesos 150 pesos por mes por mes
por no usar el refrigerador esto de luz
ok entonces que nos preguntan si carlos
se compra el nuevo de refrigerador nos
vamos a comprar un refrigerador ok en x
meses esto quiere decir que carlos
ahorro una cantidad igual a la
diferencia entre el costo del
refrigerador nuevo y la reparación del
viejo cuánto vale x ok esencialmente lo
que quiere decir esto es que si yo me
toma la diferencia de éste y este es
decir nueve mil nueve mil a esto le
quitó tres mil a esto le quitó tres mil
ok esto es exactamente lo mismo que
bueno a la diferencia de los dos pero
como si se compró el nuevo entonces lo
que me estoy dando cuenta es que él va a
ahorrar x meses dice que se cumpla el
nuevo en x meses entonces esto es lo
mismo que la cantidad de meses que el
ahorro por la cantidad que el ahorro
pero el ahorro 150 pesos al mes
150 por equis de ustedes yendo fijándome
en cuanto a ahorro por mes por la
cantidad de meses y esto tiene que ser
igual a la diferencia entre el costo de
los dos refrigeradores y bueno esto me
queda que seis mil seis mil es igual a
150 x de equipo pasar este dividiendo me
va a quedar que x es igual a seis mil a
seis mil entre 150 aquí puedo quitar un
cero con un cero y me queda 600 entre 15
pero 15 cabe cuatro veces el 60 15 por
460 entonces esto es lo mismo que 40 40
meses de subida meses tuvo que ahorrar
carlos para conseguir su nuevo
refrigerador ok y la respuesta es x
igual a 40 que por cierto es el inciso
de la respuesta es el exceso de y vamos
a resolver el problema número 5 voy a
borrar esto de aquí y vamos a hacer el
problema número 5 problema número 5
y dice el perímetro del triángulo
equilátero abc es tres veces el
perímetro del triángulo equilátero de
efe a ver pongámoslo aquí tengo un
triángulo a más o menos así algo más o
menos así y tengo otro triángulo por
cierto este es el platero y tengo otro
triángulo que es un poco más pequeño más
o menos así así y así los dos son
equiláteros ok este es el triángulo abc
ese es el triángulo de f
efe y además me dicen que el triángulo
abc este de aquí tiene el triple de
perímetro que este triángulo de aquí así
que si su lado este lado vale x a este
lado también va a valer x y este también
va a valer x porque es un triángulo
equilátero y también podemos deducir
cuánto vale el lado de cada uno de estos
porque si el perímetro de este triángulo
es 3 x su perímetro es 3x entonces
podemos deducir cuánto vale el perímetro
de este triángulo y también podemos
deducir cuánto vale uno de sus lados
pero vamos a ver qué me dice si el
perímetro del triángulo df el perímetro
de este triángulo es 10 o es que este
perímetro me lo dan el perímetro de este
triángulo es 10 y si el perímetro de
este triángulo es 10 podemos saber de
una manera muy rápida cuánto vale el
perímetro de este triángulo el perímetro
de este triángulo el perímetro es igual
a 3 veces 10 porque tiene el triple del
perímetro por lo tanto el perímetro es
y el perímetro de este triángulo es 30 y
qué es lo que me preguntan cuánto vale
cada lado del triángulo abc es decir
cuánto vale x muy bien si yo sé que el
perímetro vale 30 y yo sé que esto es lo
mismo que 3 x de aquí puedo decir que x
debe de valer 10 para que sea un
triángulo equilátero y tiene toda la
lógica del mundo si este vale 10 este
vale 10 y este vale 10 entonces tengo un
triángulo equilátero y su perímetro vale
30 de lujo ya está pause el problema
número seis así que vamos a quitar este
de kim y trabajemos en el problema
número 6 que dice lo siguiente una
máquina acuña monedas a la tasa de una
moneda por segundo ok acuña
una moneda a la tasa de una moneda por
segundo perfecto si hace esto por 10
horas cada día
ok trabaja 10 horas por día por día ok
aproximadamente cuánto tiempo le tomará
a la máquina acuñar 360 mil monedas yo
quiero saber en cuánto tiempo va a
acuñar a 360 mil monedas ok
bueno para esto vamos a ver cuánto hace
al día te parece bien si acuña una
moneda por segundo y trabaja diez horas
al día entonces en un día en un día va a
trabajar diez horas diez horas por día
esto es lo que nos dice que trabaja ok
pero cada hora de estas diez horas tiene
60 minutos entonces a esto lo podemos
multiplicar por 60 porque cada hora
tiene 60 minutos entonces minutos y acá
abajo horas 60 minutos por cada hora ya
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 60 otra
vez porque cada minuto porque cada
minuto tiene 60 segundos 60 segundos por
cada minuto y nosotros sabemos que
además acuñar una moneda cada segundo
por lo tanto esto nos va a servir justo
ahorita porque aquí estamos hablando de
una unidad de tiempo y con esto vamos a
ver cuántas monedas acuña por día una
moneda eso lo voy a multiplicar por una
moneda a moneda
entre a segundo segundo éstos son
monedas muy bien y entonces cuantos esto
bueno pues al día al día
acuña 10 x 60 x 60 lo cual de 600 por 60
lo cual es
3.600 a
3600 3600 monedas por 10 monedas por día
si la máquina trabaja 10 horas al día
ok cada día hace 3600 monedas pero yo
quiero saber en cuánto tiempo va a ser
360 mil monedas
bueno si esto es lo que hacen un día
para saber la cantidad de días realmente
tenemos esta ecuación a
3600 y esto parece 103 mil 600 por la
cantidad de días voy a ponerle x de días
esto debe de ser igual a 360 mil monedas
ok y si de aquí despejó a d me va a
quedar que d es igual a 360 mil ok esto
dividido entre 3.600 y entonces éste se
va con este este se va con este 36 136
es 1 y este 0 lo pongo aquí 10 días se
va a tardar en acuñar todas estas
monedas y esta es la respuesta del
problema número 6 en 10 días va a acuñar
todas estas monedas 10 días y esa es la
respuesta de este problema hasta la
próxima